hey this is presh tollwacker here's a
problem everyone is talking about
according to the mirror children's maths
question leaves adults stumped as some
say it makes their quote head hurt and
according to the straight times what is
the closest time to midnight Matt's
question for kids causes confusion
so here's the question
what is the closest time to midnight
answer Choice a 11 55 a.m answer Choice
B
1206 a.m answer Choice C 11 50 a.m and
answer Choice D 1203 A.M
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so I think a useful visual to work this
out is to use a 24-hour clock
we have Midnight at the top then we have
12 hours and then we have 12 noon or
midday at the bottom and then we have
another 12 hours back to midnight in
military time we have 0 hundred hours
then 100 hours going down to 1200 hours
then we go back up to 2300 hours and
then 2400 hours which is the same as 0
100 hours
so let's put each of these times on this
24 hour clock
now we just need to know a few of the
hours so we can use the simplified
version
now answer choices C and A are going to
be close to 12 noon so this will be the
times 11 50 a.m and 11 55 am
then we have answer choices D and B
which are going to be close to midnight
now the question is asking for the
closest time to midnight
and from my perspective these are the
closest times to midnight the question
does not State what is the closest time
to the next midnight in a way that time
is linear it's just saying what is the
closest so that could be time going
forward or time going backwards so we
are down to answer choices D and B and
we can eliminate answer choices C and A
now 1206 am is 6 minutes after midnight
and 1203 am is three minutes after
midnight three minutes is closer we can
eliminate answer Choice B and therefore
the correct answer is D 1203 am is three
minutes and that's the closest time to
midnight
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]